you remember this can
the sweet sauce the soft noodle this was
childhood
but did you know that chef boyardee was
an actual chef
he was his name was hector and he made a
mean pasta sauce
but it wasn't hector sauce that made
chef boyardee the household name that it
is today
you can thank the us military for that
in the 1930s
hector bearti opened up an italian
restaurant in ohio and everyone was like
oh my god i love your sauce so he
started selling it
and he sold a lot of it a lot a lot
by 1938 he had opened up his own factory
selling his sauce and pasta can ask for
chef boyardee spaghetti dinner
only about 15 cents a serving then world
war ii happened and a phone call was
made
the u.s military called hector had said
something like help make food for the
troops
he already had the canning
infrastructure so hector said all right
his company shifted from a civilian
consumer base to a military one
chef rarity became the largest supplier
of rations to us and allied forces
production was happening 24 7. by the
end of the war
the factory was too large and the
military demand no longer existed
hector didn't know what to do so he sold
it to this large company called american
home products who were all like
we got this they quickly rebranded and
distributed the can as easy to make at
at-home meals and filled supermarket
shelves across the united states
so today when we buy chef boyardee we're
actually eating rebranded world war ii
field rations yep
[Music]
there are countless chinatowns all over
the world and new york boasts one of the
most famous
full of cheap produce fish markets and
of course a plethora of chinese food
but if you hop on the one train take it
to the upper west side you'll find a
chinese restaurant like no other
where half the menu is something else
[Music]
this is la caridad 78 new york's last
cuban chinese restaurant
how did this unlikely culinary duo come
to be that's a great question
enter sam lee sorry with my wife
my father came over here he started like
his own restaurant with you know cuban
spices
and also the chinese food mixed together
hundreds of thousands of chinese came to
cuba in the 19th and early 20th century
establishing a strong presence on the
island but when castro came to power
most chinese immigrants like sam's
father left many of them coming to the
u.s
and thus cuban chinese food was born i
would say
la galida restaurant is not restaurant
it's a kitchen for upper west ciders we
have oxtail
raw baja which is like a shredded beef
at the same time we serve chinese food
either cooked from you know mainly from
china and they
learn the trade when they got here and
they become very good
so are there any cuban-born workers left
i still have a one cuban worker working
for me
my name is antonio wong i work in canada
and i started in 1986
i'm born in hamana cuba in 1951
while cuban chinese culture is fading la
caridad is a snapshot
of a strange moment in time where two
vastly different cultures merged
together
the cuban chinese people getting older
and they don't have any younger people
take over i myself feel like i owe my
father
who started this restaurant so i want to
try to
make sure that i carry on the tradition
for him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i have one job making the best clothing
in the world
my name is martin greenfield
i used to be maximilian grunfeld when i
was born
but i changed it to made it american
because i love this country my
craft is very difficult to define
because it's many things i am a maker of
clothing
i know how to measure i know how to fit
people
very few people could match me i was
responsible for all the presidents
clinton i measured in the white house
obama measured in the white house
so then i made them perfect shoes we
never had to fix nothing
my life was a sad life before i came to
america
because i lost my family i was left
alone
everybody was there we were occupied
auschwitz was a month later i was in the
concentration camp
a year and two months it was my
second day in auschwitz there's no more
names
in the concentration camp only numbers
and they called me they sent me to
taylor
the head tailor spoke my language it was
jewish
they asked me are you a tailor no i said
if you could show me how to make the
color he says i'll make you a color
show me how to make color the
pain is still in my heart about my
family
i still dream about my family like
they're
alive but on the outside
you will never know i didn't think
i was gonna survive i was liberated
by eisenhower general eisenhower came in
when i was 15 and a half years old
and when they walked in i shook his hand
crying you saved my life
i came to america september 18
1947 they gave me the job
as a tailor i told my boss listen
eisenhower liberated me i
want you to make him a trippy suit like
i wear myself
he'll liked it once he had the first
three-piece suit from then on you didn't
see eisenhower and nothing but
three-piece suits so that's how it
started
i made sure we dressed all the
presidents
uh with obama first he wanted me to copy
a suit
i don't copy anybody everybody copies my
suit so
if he wants me to make something i have
to measure
next day he sends an email be a pleasure
to meet you there
i'm happy when i'm at the factory my job
is the most important thing in my life
quality is so important to me
because i know that's what kept me in
business
and that's why i'm here talking to you
my mom is amazing person
[Music]
jeanette is and rosario vargas are a
mother and daughter
separated by a border
one living in san diego and the other
in mexico
i came from mexico 2006 because
i wanted to get another opportunity for
my kids
cuando se fuego
i don't have the permission to cross the
border
the line from the last year and a half
i see my mom to the fence
[Music]
at the site of a bi-national park in san
diego the u.s border patrol allows
families to meet
on the weekends loved ones enter the
park and walk directly up to the border
a steel fence this gives families on
both sides a rare opportunity to see
and speak to each other
you know you're gonna see your mom
you're gonna see your family
but the fans only have a tiny
hose and my mom sometimes
put the finger in the tiny hole just a
little touch it
just touch it or sometimes i give it a
kiss
is
foreign
on april 30th for the third time ever
authorities agree to open the door
allowing select families a brief moment
to embrace
each of them will only have three
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
right now i feel so happy because i'm
waiting i'm waiting so much
this moment for the third time
ever we have the opportunity to have
this door open
[Music]
i feel
[Music]
incredible she was so
happy she was so sweet with me
she told me i love you mommy i love you
so much i love you i love you
you